we also decided to come out with a
series of Prints but we're going to use
Bitcoin we're going to use the the
ordinals which are the Bitcoins version
of a of a of an ethereum nft and I'm
going to try to incorporate Bitcoin into
this piece by using the Bitcoin
blockchain as a way to authenticate the
original genuine status of these prints
to the extent that anyone who owns one
wants to sell it the buyer can have a
way of authenticating that it's not a
counterfeit that this is the actual
friend
oh
all right guys bang bang I've got Peter
here with me Peter I thought a great
place to start would be the debt limit
the debt limit crisis everyone's talking
about it it looks like it's averted talk
a little bit as to why everyone should
be paying attention to this and what is
the impact on the US economy now that
we've averted that crisis
well first of all the debt ceiling was
not the crisis that was a contrived
crisis the real crisis was for the
politicians who wanted to run up more
debt and the debt ceiling limited their
ability to do that so the crisis was
that we can't raise the debt ceiling we
have to come clean with the American
public we have to admit that we can't
provide all the benefits that we
promised and that would have been very
difficult for a lot of politicians
because they may not have gotten
reelected so they solved the crisis by
raising the debt ceiling but that allows
the real crisis to remain which is the
debt itself nobody seems to be caring
about that you know that during the the
debates before they raised the debt
ceiling a lot of people talk about how
bad it would be for American families if
we didn't raise the debt ceiling and
then the U.S got a credit downgrading
because of a default and it would mean
that rates would be higher that people
would be paying higher interest rates
well people are going to pay higher
interest rates because of the debt in
fact they're going to have to pay higher
taxes to repay the debt that is the
burden on the families it's the debt
itself the limit tries to limit that
burden but the government wants the
burden to be unlimited they want to
continue to pile on more debt that
American families are obligated to repay
either honestly through higher taxes or
dishonestly through higher prices
because they end up creating inflation
to monetize the debt
so when we look at this specific
solution it appears that they're just
kicking the can down the road for about
two years or so uh and then we will come
back to a debt limit crisis again in
about 24 months uh give or take now if
we look at uh the debt to GDP ratio here
in the United States it is significantly
lower than let's say in Japan and if we
look at Japan we see that they've been
able to go for a very long time with
that high debt to GDP do you think that
the United States is facing something in
the imminent uh kind of time frame or do
you think that the United States can
continue to play this game with debt
levels for many decades to come well
first of all when you're comparing us to
Japan I mean Japan is the exception I
mean Japan is unique in how much debt to
GDP it has uh the United States is you
know one of the highest debt to GDP
uh nations in in the world and most
countries that have uh a debt to GDP
anywhere close to ours are having a lot
of trouble right now uh so to say that
well Japan can God got away with it we
can too is not an argument that I buy
especially if you look at the
differences between Japan and the United
States
um Japan
is um a nation of Savers right the
individual Japanese
can in theory at least afford this debt
the Japanese government bonds are almost
owned exclusively by the Japanese
the Japanese don't depend on the rest of
the world to finance that debt but that
doesn't mean it's not a problem I mean
look at what's happening in Japan right
now inflation has finally broken out
it's at a 30 or 40 year high yet they
can't let rates go up because they have
so much debt so Japan is going to have a
debt crisis of its own it's not like
they've gotten away with it they're
going to have a price to pay and it's
very unfortunate uh for the Japanese
because this is not going to be a a a
low price
but
if you also look at the aggregate of
debt you can't just look at the bonds
right that's just one portion of a
nation's debt
there are other obligations that
governments are on the hook for that go
beyond the money they actually borrowed
for example in the United States the U.S
government has guaranteed all the bank
accounts it's guaranteed all the
pensions it's guaranteed student loans
it's you know guaranteed uh pensions of
retired government employees including
the military uh it has all these
commitments that are out there and these
unfunded liabilities dwarf
the funded portion of the debt you're
talking about let's say 200 trillion
dollars worth of commitments
that the US government has made
and if you can bear all the unfunded
liabilities that the U.S government is
on the hook for compared to the Japan
Japan
we're in more debt than they are and
also look at our trade deficits Japan
does not have the enormous trade
deficits that the United States has
so we've got another trillion plus per
year that we have to borrow as a nation
to maintain our standard of living the
Japanese don't have that problem they
have a budget deficit but they don't
have a trade deficit we have both and so
you have to look at the totality upon
which the U.S depends on debt and more
importantly the financing of that debt
externally
uh and so I think we are much closer to
an even bigger crisis than than Japan
about three years ago in 2020 I was
sitting in New York City I was having a
relaxing evening with my now wife and I
got a message from you and you said to
me hey gold is about to hit an all-time
high Let's do an interview live and so
you and I both got on YouTube and we did
an entire live stream interview talking
about gold about the economy Bitcoin Etc
and at the time you said something that
I think many people thought was insane I
frankly don't remember exactly what I
thought but it sounded pretty insane in
hindsight which was that at the current
period the interest rate the United
States was at zero percent there had
been two emergency rate cuts and
suppressed down to zero percent you said
that the interest rate was going to have
to rise to five to ten percent in order
to allow people to hold dollars to
address the debt Etc here we are now
with the interest rate at five percent I
don't like to tell you that you were
right but on that one specifically you
were correct talk a little bit about why
have they had to raise interest rates
from zero to over five percent and what
do you think they will have to do moving
forward given the debt given a lot of
the current market conditions and also
the health of the consumer well a you
know inflation is over five percent at a
minimum
and and so if you're going to Whole
dollars
you're losing five percent of your value
per year at a minimum and so you need to
be paid five percent just to you know
Break Even to offset that decline in
purchasing power you need more dollars
to have the same purchasing power so in
order to uh get people to hold dollars
they have to be compensated for that
loss of purchasing power but you know I
don't think five percent is going to be
enough
because I don't think inflation is going
to stay at that level I think it's going
to be higher plus people don't loan
money to break even I mean what's the
point of loaning money if at the end of
the day you're just going to break even
you need a positive return that exceeds
the rate of taxes by an amount that's
high enough to make the loan worthwhile
and of course you know the more you you
know a country borrows the higher the
risk that we might default look we just
spent several months
telling our creditors we may default
we're not even sure if we're going to
pay you back we may not raise this debt
ceiling so if I'm a creditor of the
United States why do I want to take that
chance to break even like you know best
case scenario you you keep raising the
debt ceiling and I break even with this
why but the other problem is the more
debt the U.S government has the more
likely they are to resort to inflation
printing money to pay it off rather than
Taxation and so if inflation is going to
be much higher that means my losses are
going to be much greater so you know why
bother so rates have to go up but the
thing is
because we've had no real attempt to do
anything about inflation other than
raising rates
inflation is not going away because
inflation is not about the low rates
the FED created inflation to make the
rates low because it had to print money
to buy all the bonds to suppress the
rates
but what's really driving the process is
government spending and the massive
deficits that it produces that have no
other means of financing other than
inflation the fed and we just raised the
debt ceiling with no real cuts to
government spending the deficit is going
to explode over the next two years four
or five trillion maybe more
uh so inflation is going to get worse
from here it is not going to get better
despite the fact that the FED has height
rates and in fact those rate hikes are
now working their way through the cost
structure of business just like higher
wages or higher raw material costs or
higher rents and so ultimately higher
rates are just going to be part of the
price increases that get passed on to
Consumers and that's one of the reasons
that the CPI in the future is going to
be higher than it is now
when you look at the CPI obviously it is
a 12-month kind of year-over-year
measurement uh it has been coming down
what's interesting about that that is a
12-month measurement but if you look
month over month throughout 2023 we
actually see an acceleration there's
been Positive Growth month over month of
that inflation measurement if you then
go and you look at something like
trueflation which is an alternative
method they estimate that inflation is
actually somewhere around three percent
if you talk to someone like a Barry
sternlick he thinks that inflation on
the headline number will be negative or
around zero percent sometime this summer
what's your take on where inflation is
today and where do you think that it'll
go through the rest of this year well
first of all we have so much inflation
in the pipeline because of 12 Years of
money printing right that's the
inflation the reason that the
year-over-year numbers have come down is
just because of the the comparisons we
have such a huge increase in prices the
prior year that on a year-over-year
basis at some point you're always going
to get a Improvement because of the the
comparisons the problem is going forward
over the next year you're not going to
have those same comparisons so it's
going to be much easier later in 2023
early 2024 to have year-over-year
numbers that are much worse but if you
look at the month over month numbers
just if you annualize each month each
month in and of itself we're still
showing prices increasing over the prior
month at an annualized rate of five
percent six percent seven percent and
this is cumulative this is on top of the
price increases that have already taken
place you know people were complaining
about oh prices went way up well they
keep going up that means that the the
stuff is getting even more expensive
prices are coming back down we are not
reversing any of the inflation with from
2021 2022 we're adding to it
and and there is no
um path at all forward for inflation to
come anywhere near two percent or stay
there right those days are long gone
we're permanently now back in a period
where CPI unless they find a way to
completely redo the index again so it
can you know hide the inflation to an
even greater degree we're looking at
inflation at a minimum probably four or
five six percent kind of trough and then
potentially much higher than that so
living in this world is very different
from the world where inflation was below
two percent because you know you're in a
whole new uh reality in that situation
and that requires you know new interest
rates new gold price but when the US
government
is confronted with an interest rate that
reflects that higher level of inflation
it's it's impossible to finance you know
even right now interest rates are about
consuming almost a trillion dollars a
year we're close to a trillion dollars a
year in interest in the national debt
when you and I had that conversation
that you're talking about it was maybe
300 billion a year
now you're talking a trillion
in a couple of years
If the Fed has to keep raising rates you
know let's say they even they get to six
or seven percent but more and more of
the short-term debt has a chance to roll
over plus we have to add to that all
this new debt that we're going to borrow
in two or three years it could be two
trillion dollars a year in interest on
the national debt where is this money
going to come from the US government
only collects about 4 trillion in taxes
how can 50 of tax revenue go to interest
on the debt like that's like somebody
that earns a hundred thousand dollars a
year
they have to spend fifty thousand a year
paying the interest on on their credit
cards you you can't survive with with
that uh type of interest expense so we
are headed for a debt crisis a sovereign
debt crisis and a currency crisis that's
real what we just went through with the
debt ceiling that was fake
what happens in a sovereign debt crisis
or a currency crisis what are you
expecting to uh to kind of be prepared
for well that's you know that that's
where you see a collapse of treasuries
nobody wants to buy treasuries because
the yield is not high enough to offset
for inflation and so then the FED has to
print even more money to buy the
treasuries that nobody else wants and
then an already elevated inflation rate
starts to spiral out of control and now
you're talking hyperinflation uh you
know and so that's the risk and then
what happens there well the dollar is
imploding in value the cost of living is
skyrocketing then what does the
government do well then they panic and
they impose like price controls uh
exchange controls all sorts of Desperate
Measures to try to prevent you know uh
prices from spiraling out of control uh
and then you end up with shortages uh
you end up with long lines for basic
necessities you end up with black
markets and so you turn honest Americans
into criminals because the only way they
can buy stuff is if they do it illegally
right on the black market so a lot of
this stuff is going to happen at as a
result of the fact that politicians do
not want to accept this responsibility
for what they've done level with the
American public and make the tough
political choices that are actually
necessary to Reign this problem in
before it gets out of control which
means huge cuts to government spending
and telling a lot of people that they're
not going to get what they were promised
now they're not going to get it anyway
it's just that the politicians won't
tell them that they're just going to
inflate these obligations away and so
yes you're going to get your Social
Security benefits they just won't be
worth anything when you receive them
so if you listen to somebody like
Stanley druckenmiller he's saying
exactly this right there's all these
things the US government has promised
whether it's Medicaid Medicare or
various other programs like Social
Security he believes that we have to
have a talk now about cutting
entitlements and if we don't then we're
going to have to do it later uh and it's
not really going to change so it's
better to do it up front rather than
wait it sounds like you agree with him
that we should cut entitlements and just
have that hard conversation today well
yeah I mean it's not we can't just talk
about it we've got we've got to actually
do it but but I think that there is no
political politically viable way to make
meaningful cuts
in entitlements without also making
meaningful Cuts in other parts of the
budget we have to make meaningful Cuts
in defense right uh and I I don't think
that we should leave our creditors
unscathed
uh the bond market I think that there
should be a a shared suffering
among everybody who is owed money by the
US government I mean just like in any
bankruptcy you can't take certain
creditors and say well you guys are
going to be made whole and we're going
to you know make everybody else pay so I
think that we should restructure the
debt and we should tell people who own
U.S treasuries which of course would
include the Japanese the Chinese right
the Saudis everybody
you know what we don't have the money to
pay you back
and so we're not going to do it now
we're not going to give you nothing
we're going to give you something but it
ain't going to be 100 cents on the
dollar I mean we've got to spread the
pain because I don't think people on
Social Security are going to accept the
fact that they're not going to get their
money but we're going to prioritize the
Chinese and give them all theirs so I
think there's got to be some kind of
acknowledgment
that were broke and everybody has got to
take
uh you know a haircut on what they've
been promised and if that means that we
end up with a lower credit mating well
we get a lower credit rating that that
doesn't bother me because
I want the government to live within its
means I don't want the federal
government to borrow any money maybe if
we have a lower credit rating that's a
way of getting a balanced budget we
would be better off with a balanced
budget anyway so I don't care if our
debt gets downgraded but you know in my
mind if we actually got our fiscal house
in order
which included you know a restructuring
of our treasury debt we would actually
be a better credit risk at that point
just like you know if somebody goes
through a bankruptcy and they get rid of
all their credit card debt and a lot of
stuff and they have a clean slate you
probably want to you'd be more willing
to lend that person money after they've
already wiped out all their debt you
know than before when you might end up
you know as just another creditor in a
bankruptcy so there's going to be
massive inflation to anybody who buys
U.S treasuries now but if we can get our
fiscal house in order reduce government
borrowing reduce spending balance the
budget to the extent that we did need to
borrow money for an emergency
you know we'd get a better deal we
actually needed it
but I don't think the government should
need to borrow money they have the power
to tax if you want to pay for something
then tax the people to cover the cost
and that the people don't want to pay
the taxes then don't do it you know you
know that taxation keeps government
honest right they but with inflation the
government gets to pretend they're
giving people something for nothing we
can have all these programs and you
don't have to pay for it well if I don't
have to pay for it sure I'll take the
program but if you want me to pay for it
well you know maybe I don't actually
want it and I think if Americans got the
bill for a lot of these programs that
they claim they want they really
wouldn't want them
what would it look like to get a haircut
in the bond market so it makes sense in
terms of cutting entitlements but what
does that look like in terms of the
creditors the United States
well again they take an honest haircut
instead of a dishonest one look you know
nobody's gonna get their money back I
mean that is reality so the question is
how are you going to lose as a creditor
of the United States are you going to
lose because America doesn't pay you
everything that they that was promised
or are you going to lose
because they pay you what was promised
they just pay you in a money that
doesn't buy in a money that doesn't buy
very much so you're either going to lose
to honest default or you're going to
lose to inflation but those are your
only choices you're going to lose no
matter what I think if we act fiscally
responsibly now
which would include a restructuring our
creditors are actually going to lose a
lot less
how does the banking crisis play into
all of this like obviously we saw uh
that there was this immense outflow from
Banks like Silicon Valley Bank Etc we
saw the FED uh the OCC the treasury and
other organizations step in and
basically backstop all deposits in the
United States there's a debate as to
whether that is an inflationary action
or it's not how do you read into the
banking crisis
well the banking crisis was a byproduct
of everything the the Federal Reserve
has done everything the US government
has done to create that crisis they they
you know set the stage for it a by
ensuring Bank deposits they never should
have done that of course that goes back
to the Roosevelt days right it started
in the 1930s but it was a mistake and
you know the moral hazard has grown ever
since why do you think it was a mistake
well because the government shouldn't
guarantee anything I mean Banks should
have to stand on their own credit
worthiness uh Banks should have to
compete with one another in a free
market based on uh safety that should be
a primary criteria where do you want to
put your money well I want to put my
money into a bank that doesn't do dumb
things with it I I I I recognize when
you open up a bank account you are a
creditor of that bank you are loaning
money to the bank
well how is it that you can loan money
without any regard for the ability of
the bank to pay you back I mean only the
government has done that in a free
market uh the banks that had the best
balance sheets the best loan portfolios
those are the ones that would get the
deposits
today the bank that gets the deposits is
the one that's closest to your house you
know or whatever has the easiest website
to navigate no one gives a damn about
what the bank does with their with your
money because the government has got it
all guaranteed but also the government
kept interest rates for the FED at zero
for a long time and so the only way the
banks were able to generate any return
was to go out long term even though the
returns were low there was no return on
the short-term money so the FED
basically encouraged every all these
Banks to take on uh the long-term uh
debt you know look at the mortgages I
was talking about this for years nobody
else was when everybody was talking
about how great it was that Americans
could refinance their mortgages at three
percent
I kept saying Yeah but what about the
other side of that coin what about the
banks who are going to be stuck owning
this paper for 30 years collecting three
percent what's going to happen to those
Banks when interest rates go up right
the the borrower's gain is the lender's
loss so we basically created a ticking
Time Bomb for all these banks that were
on the other side of the refinance boom
and the same thing with all the
treasuries that they bought and another
reason that Banks were loaded up on
treasuries and government guaranteed
mortgages was because the banking
Regulators encourage Banks to own them
because they punished them if they owned
anything else they forced them to take
big haircuts on those positions which
impeded their Capital the deal that The
Regulators made with the banks if you
own U.S treasuries if you own a
government guaranteed mortgage you never
have to Market to the market doesn't
matter how much
value that asset loses we're not going
to count it against you
so the banks bought it because of that
those those uh uh unfavorable accounting
treatment
now the banks just said well you know we
can pretend that we don't have these
losses because we're just going to claim
that we're going to hold these mature
these assets to maturity
well how do you know if you own a
30-year asset how do you know you're
going to be able to keep it for the next
30 Years what if something comes up and
you need to sell it right well they just
pretended that nothing would come up
well you know what's come up rates have
gone up and so now the banks are in
trouble because their customers want
their money back why because they can
put it someplace else and get a higher
yield why leave it locked up the
depositors are not locked up the banks
they're locked up that's why for years I
was warning about these Banks again
everybody was saying on Wall Street oh
interest rates going up is going to be
good Finance for financials I said no
it's going to destroy the financials
because it's going to blow up their
balance sheets it's going to cause huge
losses uh for the assets that they own
and that's exactly what happened so this
was not something that came out of left
field just like the 2008 financial
crisis it was easy to predict that's why
I was able to predict it right I can
only predict stuff that's easy to
predict right I'm not that smart right
so it has to be pretty obvious for me to
understand it early in advance and so
this is you know something that I was
talking about a warning about that
everybody else was clueless about until
it happened and then of course their
solution more government bailouts more
money printing actually makes the
ultimate problem worse
how do you think about it being a
government bailout in terms of they let
the equity and the debt holders fail but
they save the depositors is that still
considered a bailout in your mind is
that a positive or A negative thing
should they have allowed people with
more than 250 000 in those accounts to
just go to zero
well you know yes they should have
because now here's what they've done
they bailed out the large depositors
but
in doing that they communicated to the
public
that
all banks don't necessarily enjoy that
protection that it's a case-by-case
situation when a bank fails that the fed
the treasury are going to evaluate
the impact that that bank failure might
have on the economy or whatever and then
decide
whether or not they want to cover the
large deposits
and that created a huge problem for a
lot of regional and Community Banks
because now
you have the large depositors
who are thinking you know I've got my
money at some small Bank
and if this small Bank fails the FDIC
coverage for my account let's say I got
five million dollars at some small Bank
you know
I I may not be covered
so I'm going to take my money out of
that little bank I'm going to send it to
Bank of America I'm gonna send it to
some big bank that's either too big to
fail or if it fails I know they're gonna
cover everybody so the government is
actually accelerated the Run
out of smaller Banks because why would
you put your money into one of those
Banks given the fact that you know all
these banks are in trouble so why take a
chance it's not like they're going to be
able to pay you more interest and if
they did pay you more interest to offset
the higher risk that you'll lose your
money in a default it's going to put
those banks at a competitive
disadvantage so what the government has
done is is now they're moving towards
even more consolidation in the bank
industry because they've created this
problem now of course the solution to
that problem is okay let's make this an
explicit guarantee we're going to
guarantee everybody's account no matter
how large no matter where it is but then
that's an even bigger problem because
where do you get the money to do that
you know and the the whole theory behind
the deposit insurance was look we're
just going to cover the little accounts
we're not going to cover the big
accounts and it's the big depositors
that are going to keep the banks honest
right because if you put 5 10 million 20
million in a bank you're going to do
your research you're going to do your
homework because you know you're not
insured and so we're going to count on
the large depositors to police the banks
but the minute you say hey it doesn't
matter you're covered no matter what
then nobody polices the banks then it's
just the government that polices the
bank so the government can't do a good
job of it government doesn't do anything
right you need free market competition
that's the only regulation that works uh
because there you have the repo the
responsible parties held accountable for
for what they what they what they do
wrong
uh but so there is really no way out of
this
uh there's just various bad choices you
know the only real way out of it is to
is to get away from insured accounts and
you just phase it out but of course
they're not going to do that either
because the banking system is insolvent
the whole thing would collapse without
the government guarantees right now it's
on government life support all of these
Banks would be technically insolvent
today if they had to stand on their own
two feet
it's only the government guarantees that
are propping up the industry but but
that is not how you want your banking
industry to be you don't want it to be a
phony house of cards that is dependent
on government backstops because
eventually those backstops are going to
fail and the House of Cards is going to
collapse
is it fair to say that there's been a
pseudo-nationalization of the banks
given these backstops if they're
insolvent on a technical basis given
that they're underwater on so many of
the assets if the government is
essentially propping them up with this
backstop is that a form of nationalizing
banks or do you feel like yeah
absolutely look I mean you know this is
fascism you know is what we have you
know that's the type of economic system
that uh you know we have it's that that
combination of a government and uh
industry basically under government
control uh the government doesn't own
the banks but it basically controls them
uh and it it we don't have a free market
competition uh it's it's certainly not
capitalism I mean you can't call
what we have in banking capitalism I
mean you know it's it's not even close
uh so it is a form of Socialism but you
know but what form of Socialism is it
because they're you know they're it's
not communism clearly right so but
fascism is the type of socialism that
really describes what's going on and and
not just in banking I mean more so in
banking but also in other aspects of the
economy We have basically adopted uh
that type of economic system
talk to me about the real estate market
we've seen tons and tons of uh kind of
headlines talking about commercial real
estate people with remote work these
buildings are empty in major cities uh
we also see obviously interest rates
drastically moving markets into either
being illiquid from a transaction
standpoint we're seeing all cash offers
cap rates around four four and a half
percent it just seems like things are
breaking across the real estate market
how do you read into this yeah well
again
everything that is a function of
interest rates is already broken
because the FED kept interest rates at
zero for you know a decade
and real estate
is hugely impacted
by interest rates first of all
uh residential real estate
people when they shop for a home they
shop monthly payments right the actual
price of the home is irrelevant what
they look at is what are my payments you
know you know and that's how they get
qualified you know for these mortgages
and so when interest rates were very low
people could afford to pay a lot more
for houses than they can afford to pay
now when rates are not as low and so
real estate prices have to adjust by
coming down of course that exposes a lot
of problems uh because real estate is
collateral for a lot of loans and if the
real estate prices go down will the
loans go bad right we we know that we've
seen that movie uh commercial real
estate also is a huge house of cards
because when people buy commercial real
estate
um it's like a bond you're buying the
rental income
and that income is worth more when
interest rates are lower the lower the
interest rate the higher the present
value of rents and that is built into
the price of the commercial real estate
and a lot of that commercial real estate
is also collateral for a lot of loans so
the entire real estate market was a
house of cards right built on this
Foundation of zero percent interest
rates which is no longer there so you
remove the foundation whatever was built
on top of it comes collapsing down and
so that's what's happening now
you also have inflation though right and
inflation can make real estate prices go
up only because it makes the value of
money go down and so so you have counter
uh balancing forces you have inflation
that will push the price of everything
up which would include real estate but
you have Rising interest rates that are
going to push the price of assets that
are a function of interest rates down
and so you know it's a mixed bag a lot
of it depends on where the real estate
is you know what kind of real estate you
know it is and a lot of that as far as
what's going to happen with the real
estate market in this High inflationary
environment that that favors real assets
right real estate is a real asset right
and so uh but it you also have the
leverage but what I like are assets that
are not a function of Leverage right
maybe like Commodities or like gold
right that that wasn't wasn't bit up uh
based on on the cheap money but the way
people will end up making money on their
real estate in real terms are the people
who were smart enough
to lock in a 30-year loan at three three
and a half percent
and who still have maybe 25 years or so
left on that mortgage
they will make a lot of money not as a
homeowner but as a debtor because
they're not going to really have to
repay the money they borrowed
and so and that that means that the
house that they're getting you know they
didn't get it for free but they got it
for a fraction of the real price that
they paid right and it means the lenders
who loan them the money are going to
take huge losses and those are the banks
right who do they think owns or the
American taxpayer right that that is on
the other side of these these mortgages
in our conversation in 2020 gold was
trading just over nineteen hundred
dollars you were very excited because it
was nearing an all-time high Bitcoin was
trading just over ten thousand dollars
if we look today gold is flat to
slightly down Bitcoins up like 250
percent since then uh how do you look at
those two assets one being the analog
version of gold the other being at least
presented as digital gold and Bitcoin
drastically outperforming gold over the
last two to three years yeah I don't
care how you want to dress up Bitcoin it
isn't digital gold right it is so it's
got nothing to do with gold but yeah
gold did go on to make an all-time high
it got above 2000 uh after we we spoke
um Bitcoin didn't come near making
another all-time high the record high in
Bitcoin is close to 70 000 and so even
though Bitcoin had a big recovery from
that 10 000 level it did not recover to
new highs uh like gold did uh and gold
today at around
1970 is very close to its record high
it's it's not that far below it so if
you bought gold at an all-time record
high you're not losing that much money
but if you bought Bitcoin at an all-time
record high you you've lost more than
half your money so you know there's a
they're very different uh types of
assets
um I think going forward
uh gold is going to shine as a store
value as a monetary alternative to Fiat
currencies
uh and I think a Bitcoin is going to be
seen in a different light I think that
you know Bitcoin is a speckle of uh
digital token uh that Rose uh and and
fell and Rose and fell uh but I don't
think it ultimately has anything to do
with gold
uh despite the fact that some people
um uh have confused it for some digital
form of gold
uh yeah Bitcoin rallied just like you
know the NASDAQ rally you know a lot of
stocks are higher than they were when we
spoke a couple of years ago
uh the interesting thing though is
recently like last months for example
you had a huge month the NASDAQ was up
about six percent the the NASDAQ 100 was
up eight percent and Bitcoin got
clobbered last month so it's kind of
decoupled uh from uh the NASDAQ
um and and so if if bitcoin's not going
to go up with the NASDAQ and it's not
gonna go up with gold and then What's it
gonna go up with maybe nothing maybe
it's just gonna start going down but you
know I wanted to talk to you and I
reached out to you too about you know
the Bitcoin Community is now like real
excited because they think I'm I'm I I
joined the club hold on one second we're
gonna get to you becoming a bitcoiner
but I want to uh talk about uh Bitcoin
and gold for a second so Bitcoin is up
60-ish percent to start the year it's
the best performing asset in q1
destroyed gold uh in terms of financial
return but what I think is interesting
about this is
um Bitcoin being a speculative tool
would you agree that gold stocks
Commodities everything is a speculative
tool or do you think Bitcoin is uniquely
speculative versus maybe gold or
something else
no I mean there's a degree of
speculation in in just about everything
I just think that the degree that
there's speculation in Bitcoin is much
higher because you know Bitcoin is all
speculation it's 100 speculation because
there's there's nothing actually there
beyond the speculation
you have other things that are less
speculative
um I mean gold stocks there are many
things that you speculate on when you
choose to buy a gold mining company in
addition to what happens to the price of
gold that's just one aspect of it there
are a lot of other risks that are
inherent in operating a gold mine right
so all those risks uh are going to weigh
on the ultimate value or price of a gold
stock so you can't invest in gold stocks
unless you are comfortable uh assuming
those risks and speculating on all these
various outcomes that may or may not
happen that would result in a a gain in
uh in that stock
but you know Bitcoin it's all
speculation there is nothing to fall
back on that is not speculative
um and and so gold
has a lot less risk than a gold mining
stock right because you know the only
risk you have really if you own physical
gold and you have it in your house the
only risk you really have other than the
fact that you could lose it which is you
know you could you know or somebody
could steal it from you right
but it's the price well the price go up
will the price go down
um and so that's a lot less to worry
about than operating a gold mine where
all sorts of things could go wrong I
mean the price of gold can go up and you
could lose 100 in your gold mine right
so it you know it there are a lot of
aspects there but that's why you know
what I tell people should invest in gold
stocks diversify hire an expert that's
you know when I form my gold fund I
didn't even manage it I hired a guy that
knew more about it than me right Adrian
day I mean I know enough to buy gold I
know enough to invest in gold stocks but
I don't know enough to know which ones
are the best especially when it comes to
the junior Miners and so I want to hire
a guy that does nothing but analyze
these stocks and is very familiar with
the managements and the projects and you
know Adrian's been doing this 30 40
years and so to the extent that you want
to speculate on gold stocks and to me I
think it's a great speculation I think
the risk reward and that's always what
you want to look at whenever you're
speculating you want to try to balance
okay if I'm right how much can I make if
I'm wrong what can I lose and try to
figure out the possibility assign a
probability of success versus failure
and kind of way
the expected outcome the return and I
think on a risk reward basis you know
the amount of money that you can make in
the mining sector if I'm right about
what's going to happen is is so skewed
relative to what you could lose
uh that it's a great speculation to make
that doesn't mean you can't lose you can
but I just think the probabilities and
the potential skewed reward to risk uh
is worth it if you can afford to lose
money some people can't some people
doesn't matter how much they might make
all they just can't lose anything well
in which case you can't you can't get in
the sector but you know we have other
Investments right I manage money for
people in just basic dividend paying
foreign stocks I think are also good
inflation Hedges they don't have as much
upside as a Gold stock portfolio but
they have significantly less downside
and in the short run they'll pay more
income you'll get higher dividends which
also offsets the risk because you're
getting compensated uh with current
income that you can use so and you know
a way that people can kind of figure out
you know a portfolio is by speaking with
my reps you know getting talking to the
people at your specific asset management
about what type of portfolio is going to
best suit you based on your own
individual objectives and risk tolerance
but everybody needs to do something
because inflation is a huge risk and
mitigating that risk I think is the
single most important thing any investor
can do recognizing how high inflation is
going to be how long it's going to
persist and making the appropriate
changes to your portfolio to guard
against that risk and that's why you
know again I would encourage your
audience uh to contact us and and and
and and look into how that you can
incorporate these strategies into your
portfolio even if you have some of your
money in Bitcoin because that's another
risk that you have to hedge because you
need to worry about the fact that I
could be right and your Bitcoin could be
headed for zero okay that was a
fantastic sales pitch that you slipped
in there congratulations talk to me
about
you hammered it in all right talk to me
talk to me about becoming a bitcoiner
Peter Schiff is now a bitcoiner Peter
Schiff has an inscription where he is
going to auction it off you are a user
of the Bitcoin blockchain you have
become a promoter of the Bitcoin
blockchain why is Peter Schiff now a
bitcoiner yeah well so I'm not a
bitcoiner and now I I'm under the
delusion that Bitcoin is some digital
version of gold right but what I am
doing and it's interesting that the
people in the Bitcoin Community are so
desperate for my approval you know it's
like that anything I do any little thing
I do in the direction of Bitcoin gets
blown out of proportion right because
it's like you guys are a bunch of little
kids trying to trying to win you know my
my approval right you want you you need
that from me right which okay is fine I
get it you know but so look
a good buddy of mine who's a very
talented artist who I is a neighbor of
mine in Puerto Rico I've known him for
years
um he's a big Bitcoin guy from way back
so he's one of the most successful
Bitcoin guys
uh as far as having a very very large
net worth in part because of having
gotten into Bitcoin early right and and
that's what a lot of the people I've met
you know in Puerto Rico that live in my
neighborhood a lot of these guys got
into Bitcoin early and that that's why
they've got so much money now that's not
the only reason some of them you know
they made money in other uh Endeavors
but they also made a lot of money in in
Bitcoin so he made a lot of money and
he's always you know had some Bitcoin
element in his art you know he tries to
incorporate Bitcoin stuff in a lot of
his artwork you know
um but anyway so
about a year ago he made we I had to
make a painting for me
of a bar goal
um and you know we were playing around
with how to incorporate Bitcoin into it
but we never really I mean you you know
put the Bitcoin itself in the art
but he was doing he's doing his show in
New York which you could go buy it they
just I think they opened today
the show it's uh it's the galleries on
Madison Avenue
um and it's going to be going through I
think June and his work is on display
but we put that painting that he did for
me on display and I said okay you know
let's sell it let's auction it off
anybody who wants to buy this Peter
Schiff gold painting it's you know I
didn't paint it market price paint it
we're both gonna sign it but we also
decided to come out with a series of
prints 50 individually numbered prints
so if you can't buy the the original oil
painting but you want to have one of
these prints that's signed by by me and
the artist you can get that but we're
going to use
Bitcoin we're going to use the the
ordinals which are the Bitcoins version
of a of a of an ethereum nft
and I'm going to try to incorporate
Bitcoin into this piece by using the
Bitcoin blockchain as a way to
authenticate
the the the the uh original genuine
status of these prints
to the extent that anyone who owns one
wants to sell it the buyer can have a
way of authenticating that it's not a
counterfeit that this is the actual
print because it corresponds to this
ordinal right and I can track the
ownership of this print from day one and
no okay yes you are the original owner
and I'm buying it from you or I'm buying
it from somebody who bought it from the
original owner and so you don't have to
worry about the fact that you're buying
some kind of fake and and so trying to
find a way to use blockchain in a way
that actually adds some type of value
what that means a Satoshi is worth I got
no idea okay I don't think it's worth
anything near where it currency
currently is but I'm going to
incorporate it and the reason I think
that this is
an opportunity
for Bitcoin
assuming I am wrong about Bitcoin I
don't assume that but there are a lot of
people like you who assume that I'm
wrong I do believe
that historically I could go down as the
the the most wrong person on bitcoin I
think right now within the Bitcoin
Community I am the single best known
Bitcoin critic and I even asked chat GPT
who is the biggest most well-known
Bitcoin critic in the Bitcoin community
and it said Peter Schiff
are you proud people know me huh are you
proud of that yeah yes I am proud of
that okay I'm also the most well-known
gold bug I asked chat GPT who is the
most well-known gold bug in the world
and again it came back with me
and so goals CPT sometimes lies though
well it you know why would it lie I mean
it doesn't have you know it's not a
human right it doesn't have emotion but
my point is this if Bitcoin replaces
gold
and I am the biggest gold bug if Bitcoin
succeeds and I'm the most well-known
early critic of Bitcoin
to have the only work of art that I
commissioned or the first because
obviously I can do it again but to have
the first work of art that I
commissioned and the first set of
ordinals or any ordinal that I did and I
put on a blockchain if any of these
things are going to have value in the
future if anybody's you know nft or
um you know ordinal if anybody is going
to create something that has value it's
going to be this
you know because I'm basically saying in
your face Bitcoin I'm basically holding
up this bar gold it's not my arm it's
just a symbolic arm that is holding gold
up in Victory
now what if it turns out that I was
wrong here is this old guy claiming that
gold is supreme and it was just around
the corner and it was destroyed by
Bitcoin and so here is something to
commemorate uh you know that uh the you
know the the my the holdout or whatever
so I I think it could have some value
but also even if I'm completely right
about Bitcoin and it goes away the
original work of art forget the ordinal
because I'm not I'm not selling the
ordinals the ordinals are a freebie you
get that for free I'm just selling a
print that's all so at the end of the
day you've got a sign print my signature
is on it what's my signature gonna be
worth on that print in 100 years what's
the artist's signature gonna be worth I
don't know what's that original gonna do
I don't know it could have a lot of
value right so there's some there's a
speculative element in there uh but you
know I'm just giving Bitcoin and
bitcoiners an opportunity to own one of
these things and decide whether or not
they think that because I remember when
you know people started selling their
tweets I never actually took time to
sell anybody but there was some fool
that offered to pay several thousand
dollars for one of my anti-bitcoin
tweets you know I never actually
bothered to sell it you know because I
just didn't feel like you know doing
what I needed to do to get the money
but somebody was willing to buy it so
let me just
um uh conclude our conversation because
I know that we both have to run to
something else here but I just want to
explain that you now are a Bitcoin user
you may not be a Bitcoin proponent but
you are a Bitcoin user and as a yes I
will be I will be using Bitcoin to
inscribe these ordinals and
I will the the auction and you got to go
to the website right put you should put
it up there I forget is the market price
a website
um
to you have to register in order to bid
but we are accepting bids in Bitcoin you
you can pay for the uh Prince if you
submit a winning bid because only 50
people are going to get a print right so
you have to be one of the top 50 uh
bidders now of course if you don't win
the print at the auction you could buy
one in the secondary Market that may
develop it'll be interesting to see like
what happens to these prints after after
I you know float them right somebody
somebody can result and then of course
you could also be you could also bid on
the original oil painting that is the
one that is on display right now in that
art gallery so anybody that's in the New
York area you know I think I think you
should put in a bit I think that that
painting would look nice in your office
there
um but um the last thing I'm gonna say
is I just want everyone to know that I
am proud of you for having open minds
becoming a Bitcoin user and after all
these years after we've all weathered
you down like why water hitting a rock
over and over and over again you finally
are a bitcoiner and so Peter Schiff I I
appreciate you joining us today Anthony
what if nobody wants to buy these prints
then I you know that then that's going
to kind of like hey it doesn't even work
nobody nobody wanted them so I I'm a
potential Bitcoin user it actually works
to work people have to want to buy these
I mean I you know
I I don't know people might want the
prince anyway even if there was no
ordinal but we'll see we'll see how
successful we'll see what kind of value
these ordinals add to these prints if
any and it'll be interesting for me to
watch because once I sell them they're
gone like I don't own any other ones so
there's only 50. I'm not gonna make I'm
not going to inflate the Supply right
I'm not going to make 51 52 53. so once
I sell them I don't I don't own them
anymore so it'll be interesting to see
you know what happens to them in the
market and to the extent that you know
these ordinals add any value but again I
I if I was a bitcoiner and I had a lot
of money in Bitcoin I would want to own
one of these Peter Schiff market price
original uh Bitcoin art and gold
all right ladies and gentlemen Peter
Schiff thank you so much I appreciate it
we will definitely do it again in the
future
all right Anthony take care